die wenigsten menschen wollen sterben
unsere instinkte helfen uns tag für tag
zu überleben
wir essen gehen autos aus dem weg und
nehmen abstand von steilen klippen aber
auch bewusst versuchen wir den tod
aufzuschieben
wir gehen ins fitnessstudio ersten
gesunde dinge und versuchen jeden tag
10.000 schritte zu gehen weil das eben
gesund ist die angst vor dem tod führt
uns sogar dazu dass wir konstrukte wie
ein leben nach dem tod erfinden um sich
nicht mit der traurigen wahrheit
abfinden zu müssen denn die wahrheit ist
wir alle müssen irgendwann mal sterben
nur ist das etwas schlechtes herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge doktor
watson im sorry das so lange gedauert
hat mit der neuen freude aber ich musste
auch erst mal 80 jahre alt werden bis
wir das jetzt auf den kunden aber jetzt
geht es ja noch viel spaß mit dem neuen
video
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
dem pm magazin entstanden bei dem es in
der aktuellen ausgabe auch darum geht ob
wir das altern besiegen und so viel
länger leben können
durch die zusammenarbeit habe ich einige
spannende einblicke in dieses
faszinierende thema erhalten und ihr
könnt an einem gewinnspiel von pm
magazin teilnehmen
zu gewinnen gibt es ein hochwertiges
teleskop von bresser mit automatischer
steuerung wie ihr am gewinnspiel
teilnehmen könnt das erfahrt ihr am ende
des videos anti aging das klingt für
viele erst mal nach falten cremes und
falschen versprechen tatsächlich haben
sich in den letzten jahren unter diesem
begriff aber einige forscher start-ups
und großunternehmen zusammengefunden die
ernsthaft vorhaben den alterungsprozess
aufzuhalten oder sogar umzukehren und
das ist kein hokuspokus sondern richtige
wissenschaft die medizin
nobelpreisträgerin elizabeth blackburn
schreibt zum beispiel das altern sei ein
dynamischer prozess der beschleunigt
oder verlangsamt und zum teil sogar
rückgängig gemacht werden kann das zu
bewerkstelligen ist keine leichte
aufgabe aber blackburn hat schon einen
guten hinweis darauf gegeben wo man
anfangen sollte die molekularbiologin
hat in ihrer forschung nämlich telomere
untersucht die bestehen aus dem gleichen
material wie unser erbgut nämlich einem
strang von basenpaaren
sie sitzen an den enden der chromosomen
und sind dazu da das erbgut bei der
zellteilung zu schützen
bei jeder zellteilung werden die
telomere um 20 bis 200 basenpaare kürzer
nach circa 50 bis 95 teilungen ist dann
schluss
der schutz der telomere ist aufgebraucht
und die zelle wird sinnes cent sie ist
zwar nicht teilt sich aber auch nicht
mehr
das ist vermutlich ein eingebauter
schutz der zelle um zu verhindern dass
sich tumore bilden leider sind sie das
zehnte zellen im körper aber echt
unangenehm
sie können nicht mehr richtig mit dem
rest des körpers kommunizieren schütten
entzündungsfördernde substanzen aus und
sorgen so für viele unannehmlichkeiten
des alterns wir werden anfälliger für
schmerzen bekommen herzkrankheiten
osteoporose oder arthrose also
gelenkverschleiß letzteres versucht ein
start up aus dem silicon valley zu
bekämpfen
durch ein mittel mit den namen bbx 0 1 0
1 das ins kniegelenk injiziert wird
sollen sinneszellen zur apoptose also
zum selbstmord gebracht werden
im tierversuch umfunktionierte das
mittel bereits der knüppel abbau ging
zurück und neu knorpelzellen bildeten
sich das data wird unter anderem von
amazon gründer jeff bezos und paypal
gründer peter thiel finanziert das sonst
so junge silicon valley macht sich also
langsam gedanken ums altwerden auch
interessant ist die neue methode der
einzelzelle analyse oder auch single
cell sequencing hiermit können forscher
das erbgut einzelner zellen auslösen und
sogar erkennen welche gene gerade
aktiviert sind und welche proteine in
der zelle hergestellt werden
mit dieser methode wird es in zukunft
hoffentlich möglich unseren körper noch
viel detaillierter zu verstehen und zu
begreifen was in unseren zellen
eigentlich passiert wenn wir alt werden
dabei helfen soll das internationale
projekt human sandlers das ziel ist es
alle 40 billionen zellen des körpers auf
einer dreidimensionalen karte zu
sortieren
das projekt erinnert an das human genom
projekt bei dem erstmals das erbgut
eines menschen vollständig ausgelesen
wurde mit dem unterschied dass beim zell
atlas künstliche intelligenz eingesetzt
werden muss um diese unglaublichen
datenmengen zu verarbeiten
vielleicht am erfolgreichsten ist bisher
das biotech-unternehmen interview im
jugend diesem ist es angeblich gelungen
das biologische alter mehrerer männer in
einem zeitraum von einem jahr um ganze
18 monate zu verringern
die männer erhielten einen mix aus
medikamenten unter anderem einen
wachstumshormonen und ein mittel gegen
diabetes
daraufhin wuchs neues gewebe in der für
das immunsystem wichtigen thymusdrüse es
wäre das erste mal dass medikamente das
biologische alter von menschen gesenkt
hätten
aber je nachdem wen man fragt ist das
erst der anfang der futurist ray
kurzweil ist der leiter der technischen
entwicklung bei google und glaubt dass
anti aging wald exponentielle
fortschritte machen wird so wie
mikroprozessoren alle zwölf bis 24
monate ihre leistung verdoppeln soll ab
2029 auch das wissen um unseren körper
und unsere zellen rasant anwachsen
für kurzweil ist der menschliche körper
nur eine maschine ein system das ein
fehler hat nämlich den tod
und den kann man beheben ab 2045 soll es
soweit sein
ab dann steigt die lebenserwartung laut
kurzweil jedes jahr um einen jahr in
anderen worten wenn man nur bis zum jahr
2045 überlebt lebt man ewig denn all die
kleinen start-ups die gerade an ideen
gegen das altern forschen haben bis
dahin ausgereifte lösungen entwickelt ob
gentherapie cell reparaturen oder nano
roboter die im körper herum schwirren
und medikamente direkt zu den
tumorzellen bringen alles scheint
möglich
natürlich hat kurzweil für diese grünen
behauptungen einiges an kritik
einstecken müssen
nur weil der technologische fortschritt
exponentielles gilt das noch lange nicht
für unser verständnis vom menschlichen
körper
aber selbst wenn kurzweil recht behält
und wir in 25 jahren nicht mehr durch
krankheiten oder altersschwäche sondern
nur noch durch unfälle sterben können
würden wir das überhaupt wollen was
würden wir mit unbegrenzt viel zeit
anfangen ist die menschliche psyche
überhaupt für die ewigkeit geschaffen
wie sieht ein 300 jähriges leben aus
haben wir überhaupt noch die motivation
große projekte anzugehen wenn keinen
zeitdruck mehr da ist müsste man für
immer arbeiten wenn man nicht weiß wann
man stirbt und wahrscheinlich denn sonst
würde das ganze renten system
zusammenbrechen
vorausgesetzt natürlich dass alle
menschen plötzlich nicht mehr eltern
würden aber das wiederum setzt voraus
dass diese technologien nicht nur den
reichen und privilegierten vorbehalten
sind
eine zweiklassengesellschaft könnte
entstehen die der ewig lebenden und die
der normalsterblichen nur wer genug geld
hat kann sich den luxus eines langen
lebens können wobei wirklich anders als
heute ist das eigentlich auch nicht wie
lösen wir das problem der
überbevölkerung zehn milliarden menschen
leben in 30 jahren auf diesem planeten
was machen wir wenn sie auch für immer
bleiben wollen
wie viele kinder kann eine gesellschaft
bekommen in der menschen
durchschnittlich 150 jahre alt werden
und wer entscheidet wer diese kinder
bekommen darf bis dass der tod uns
scheidet wird auf jeden fall plötzlich
antiquiert zumindest ein aspekt könnte
sich aber verbessern
der umweltschutz wenn man weiß dass man
in 100 jahren noch hier ist dann geht
man mit diesem planeten vielleicht auch
anders um vielleicht doch nicht
der philosoph martin heidegger fand dass
der tod das leben erst definiere und ihm
eine richtung gibt
was meint ihr gehört der tod zum leben
dazu oder sollten wir versuchen diesen
fehler im system zu beheben und würdet
ihr euren alterungsprozess aufhalten um
für immer jung zu sein schreibt es mir
gerne unten in die kommentare ich bin
mega gespannt was er zu diesem thema zu
sagen habt ich lese wie immer alles und
versuche auf möglichst viele kommentare
zu antworten
wie am anfang schon angekündigt
veranstaltet das pm magazin ein
gewinnspiel bei dem ihr ein teleskop
gewinnen könnt das teleskop ist das
bresser mit dem cx 102
das modell habe ich zusammen mit euch
auf twitter ausgesucht weil es super für
einsteiger geeignet ist und mit der
besteuerung auch automatisch objekte am
sternenhimmel finden und drücken kann
zusätzlich zu der chance auf diesen
hauptgewinn bekommt jeder teilnehmer der
möchte zwei gratis ausgaben des pm
magazins inklusive der aktuellen ausgabe
da drin sind noch viel mehr infos
stories und interviews zum thema ewiges
leben also falls euch das thema
interessiert schaut auf jeden fall da
rein und ansonsten natürlich auch der
letzte ausgabe wie immer prall gefüllt
mit spannenden themen es geht um
forschung auf der internationalen
raumstation iss geht um künstliche
intelligenz im stadtverkehr es geht um
vulkan forschung sehr spannend alles den
link zum gewinnspiel und die
teilnahmebedingungen findet ihr wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung
oder sonst ein film fürs zuschauen und
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]